Comcast leased original film franchise
continues to be produced by ironically
named company here's yet another fast
and furious road with no one on it but
our main characters gonna be a great
father Brian wait did they drag race
just to be here for the childbirth is
there ever a time these guys think you
know what today is not a day to risk my
life let's carpool enemy auto for once
let's go for a little ride fast and
furious flashback montage opening
credits sequence right let's read your
file now I'm going to read the file out
loud to the audience but will let it
slide because it's awesome their sex is
made better by remembering their former
lovers deaths it wasn't that hard to
find you Toretto this surprise visit
brought to you by Under Armour I need
your help Dom I made your team well it
should be easy to brand them away from
their retired millionaire lives in order
to take down a crew that does the exact
same illegal things they did to become
millionaires in the first place just
because your old girlfriend is involved
I am NOT the director of photography on
this movie everyone at this table enjoys
a nice coca-cola except one who ordered
it pop the top and then just left it
full movie' expects me to believe this
kind of third world ATM rigging bulls is
possible despite the fact that it's in
some sort of container where I can't
actually see the food right now so glad
to see these two I didn't care about
from the last movie are still together
starting a life together
maybe but something tells me this
conversation is going to get interrupted
by something so you can't answer this
right now
also clearly you aren't since Tokyo
Drift technically comes after this movie
and you aren't in it so clearly you're
going to die
at least until franchise need you back
is this a situation these two have been
in enough in order to get into formation
and if so how many times did it work
when they were completely surrounded no
franchise in history has done as much to
push be beer as this one
Letty's dead Dom somehow despite the
fact that I was in the FBI when she died
and she was working for me at the time I
don't have any real evidence of her dead
body for some reason and don't give me
that because someone else's body burned
and they couldn't verify it both either
I'm wondering if she really died sunset
or targets on straw depicted here in the
middle of a military operation having
his picture taken like he's on vacation
and of course this secret meeting
warehouse garage has vending machines
because why wouldn't it
the mouse and there was no quieter or
safer way to tell you that we gettin
paid right yeah you don't definitely
earn that paycheck tyrese I know this
place is surrounded by police but do you
put a wire on someone out in the open
like this I just got confirmation on
stop it going in arresting one man
requires all the Interpol police
scanners are saying alarms are going off
at Interpol headquarters you brought us
here so you could take down Interpol
because much like the police station and
bad boys
Interpol decided to empty their entire
station to go after one dude which is
notable because that has been the case
in every other previous movie as well
how did Sean read all these columns with
explosives that nobody could see they'd
have to be inside the columns right how
do you manage that especially in the
time yet
Interpol designs in a major operation
that roadblocks are for suckers man both
of these movies are worthless you want
me to blow all three drivers how are any
of our heroes cars fit for driving after
the hail of machine gunfire they just in
do it show us like a more villainy
Batman with all sorts of wonderful toys
but this weapon makes you unable to
control your car that's it
all sorts of explosive technology could
be implemented here but this will just
end up causing a wreck which these guys
survived all the time and oh yeah
he survives this what just now
Brian ninja drives so this car grenade
thing gets knocked off which is bullshit
regardless but it's extra bolt since it
was launched in the front bumper where
he could never in a million years see it
to know its location well enough to do
that doesn't that mean you both left at
specific times and drove at specific
speeds despite traffic and police
interference to get here at the same
time
wrecks are meaningless this inch girl is
not amazed by Brian's survival however
it is a perfect opportunity to wink at
him and establish superiority running
into things simply does not matter you
also Hobbs jumps out of his vehicle and
lands on a car that while he's in midair
should be long gone due to things like
science they were not only able to
survive the crashes but recover the cars
and drive back with no problem you don't
hunt but if they did then they aren't
family anymore according to this motto
right somehow despite never really
seeing their faces or knowing their
names this crew is able to find all the
hero's rap sheets with no information
whatsoever you might want to send us a
picture that is strangely a surprise
despite the fact that the blonde chick
neatly stacked all this evidence into
one big file before presenting it to the
team
Shawn somehow even has a screenshot of a
moment from the first fucking movie yeah
that's the guy I shot it's weird that
I'm in this picture tube and I chose not
to acknowledge that I don't remember him
and Nisha you heard that flip car going
through those gears sequential
transmission it didn't sound like a
normal engine
oh my guess everyone in this scene gets
at least one line count democratic also
this is the scene that could have used a
nice long take this scene has cut to
death and we're not even in a confusing
action sequence but I guess a long take
would require everyone remembering their
line we find the guy who made their car
we find Shaw because underground auto
mechanics who build custom Batmobiles
just happen to know the address of
extremely careful international
criminals kitchen help entrance is
towards the back this unnecessary
prejudiced person assumes entirely too
much for the audience's amusement item
in offense gentlemen this entire scene
means offense to me clearly you're not a
baller this man's face goes way too
unpunched for me supposed to do plan on
heart I'll be big paycheque Tyrese it's
specific to one handgun PSF everything
in the Fast and Furious world comes from
one freaking source making
investigations look so easy I just
passed the FBI exam sitting in my
apartment masturbating to porn after a
handful of truly terrible line readings
Gina Carano finally explains her reason
for being in this film bastard so this
guy's comeuppance is that he has to give
his clothes to the rock
prejudices fought one garment at a time
ladies and gentlemen also this scene
where they bully this guy into taking
off his shirt is so Michael Bay it makes
me ask how can people pile on the
Michael Bay transformers hate train and
still defend this fucking both series
here what is it that makes you see them
as differ
Damle some his Clippers fresh hilarity
these women somehow miss the obvious
beep this phone makes doesn't the gaping
hole in this window negate the purpose
of having such a secure boot also he
keeps his weapons just far enough away
to be useless in a pinch what is
straight Raisa where can we find her
these guys actually went to a pawn shop
expecting the owner to know anything of
the whereabouts of the woman who came in
to buy guns from him earlier
I guess you follow every lead but this
is extremely worthless movie wise is
this how you execute people yeah these
are supposed to be professionals
seriously it would need to bring braga
back also this spits out one helpful
name before dying because he totally
rethought his life choices in the last
30 seconds became a good guy totally
this is one of the only gunshots in this
entire franchise to be super accurate
dude you had all the space on the right
side it's not like it needed to run in
one direction the whole time the bodies
go out like little bitches and of course
try to apprehend him one by one and
don't call for backup the Sheila
Rodriguez sort of holds her own in a
fight with gina carano guy who was
running from these two a minute ago
suddenly feels the need to stay here and
fight more dudes and waste more time
both women survive this without
paralysis meanwhile somehow no other
cops have been called to the scene and
this fight has gone on for ages train
that is just now leaving because it's
convenient ex machina well they got
their asses kicked makes you wonder how
they survived those massive wrecks with
absolutely no injuries Barbara is dead
you made a mistake ladies been working
with this guy for a while now and it's
just now coming to the shocking
conclusion that he's not that
sentimental Braga will know what Shaw's
up to don't they have that dude cell
phone though he punched the button and
it called one of Shawn's men okay you
find out a lot more from this cell phone
than you came by flying into the u.s.
and risking arrest just to talk to Braga
funny how we never see anyone actually
drinking NOS in these movies but there
are always cans on display I'm the one
that served her up to Braga and then did
a job actually investigating anything
related to her death I'm actually a bad
guy and good guy as it turns out
handshaking contest it's always
something O'Conner how did you keep
running around the world breaking every
law known to man and yet here I am with
my job on the line these guys never got
along in the fourth Fast and Furious
movie and there was no hey man I hate
you but I respect you see and we're
supposed to believe that this FBI guy
gives a shit about nabbing Shaw who's
wanted by Interpol and does most of his
crime outside America also why couldn't
Hobbs bones
strings on this better yet why doesn't
he get somebody to talk to Braga it's a
24-hour need to be edited by 9:00 a.m.
that's when forensics who run your
fingerprints to the national database
not to mention that's when all the
assholes who saw your face plastered all
over TV during the last movie will
suddenly recover from their memory lapse
that you're a highly one--at fugitive
named Brian O'Conner yeah and this guy
would be excellent at cinemasins movie
is full of unbelievable bullshit but
this harpoon gag may be the hardest for
me to swallow tell me something because
I very well know you didn't in fact this
is the first time you've even
acknowledged you were around her dead
body did they not have DNA dental
records or any kind of real
identification and again don't give me
that some other body burned beyond
recognition bull humor me please
villain spills evil plan details to his
enemy instead of just killing him
Phoenix decides now I want to shoot her
directly I'll let a violent expansion or
bursting with noise decide this Shawn in
the hospital two days later he went to
finish the job what told Shawn to go to
the hospital did Phoenix find this guy
Shaw who was not his boss in Fast and
Furious and tell him man I blew up this
car and I'm pretty sure lady died but
you might want to go check the local
hospitals and see if he turned up
because I did not verify whether or not
she died also this hospital had no idea
who Letty once didn't call any law
enforcement whatsoever an international
criminal Shawn was just hanging around
LA looking for random tough street
racing chicks this is some bullshit just
to get Letty back in the franchise
because he's a main character movie will
now allow Brian to win this unwinnable
prison ship fight I'm dying so I might
as well tell you Oh everything also so
far we've seen nothing that Shawn knows
anything about what's coming when it
comes to Brian and Dom's crew and the
last scene the only reason he knew was
because this dude called them in the
scene perform that they didn't even know
who they were
this is setting up the big Reilly
surprise later but she's done a poor job
telling Shawn jack ten in full seconds
of a nighttime London establishing shot
Bravo moving Bravo
every damn one of these priests
retracing scenes at the exact damn same
for all I know they shot this for too
fast too furious and inserted it into
this movie also didn't you spend time in
this film talking about the big brother
surveillance state of London maybe some
street races take place but neon dance
parties with this many people would be
quashed in a hurry ready ready to drive
sure but can you tell me what the course
is because I look
we just got here it's goddamn Piccadilly
Circus and only one cop shows up to
track these illegal street racers down
come on we need to stop street racing so
we can stop this movie in its tracks
even further by having an intimate
moment just because you know how I ride
doesn't mean you know me people with
amnesia shouldn't say like this to
people that obviously know the scar
like this scar in here scar history what
else do you know about me I know your
favorite sexual positions your favorite
beer your tattoos and birthmarks Jesus
woman what's it gonna take for you
someone with amnesia to be open to the
idea that someone else knows you very
well some kid trying to show off lost
control this is this girl's entire
backstory filled with surviving odds
defying ridiculous car accidents okay
I've been giving her a hard time for not
trusting him more but trusting him this
much for a sexy hair touch now she's
trusting too much how about this one
what the fuck okay I'm now in camp
you're trusting him way too much right
now predictable means vulnerable and
that means I can reach out and break you
whenever I want
so do it this will not go on that's deep
because this inspiring tale has come to
an end
if that's where does her go does hobbes
who is behind down no there's a laser
sight pointed at him because he did that
right on cue and since he tracked Dom
here why didn't he bring more people to
a restaurant right now good god man I
want a woman list already no would have
happened if I didn't put that tracker in
your car not to mention spending five
minutes with Letty discussing scar
tissue we were able to track Shaw after
you left you and down but this guy's
smart
so we can only track him so far if only
we have more people who aren't doing
anything right now who could have been
there when Sean went to go kill DOM if
only we had people who were like really
awesome drivers who could maybe have
followed it or even better than theirs
stop him from getting in his car in the
first place damn oh well back to the
digital surveillance so you think you've
got Sean located and you're going in
with two people holding revolvers Rock
looks down at the exact spot where the
crucial evidence is haha funny but how
many Marvel characters is Dwayne Johnson
supposed to be in this movie he's
Captain America requires clearance now
he's Thor next up Black Widow yeah that
paint you got from Saul's place highly
specialised of course it is fine
whatever you found out that's for you
discount Morpheus also Bryan's highly
risky impossible
trip to the US to find Braga was
basically so we could find out what he
already knew and it's that lady didn't
die I got amnesia and was recruited by
Shaw plus some bullsh Crockett didn't
even have to volunteer
raagh is the only way you get near Shaw
is if he wants you to information that
was strangely volunteered without any
good reason but will help us now
so Braga is to be trusted completely
that goes without saying right
former cartel leader I mean this guy
knows he's in the convoy great now call
Hobbs on the phone or radio and tell him
that and problem solved right right so
you think a huge heavily armed criminal
is coming for this thing and you decide
to move it with to personnel trucks as
the only backup let's go military
personnel carrying an important
component do not notice this
military-grade vehicle behind them
clearly up to no good will cause this
truck to start rolling on the ground
like that also good guy truck goes
flying off bridge but other good guys
driving cargo truck with obvious rear
view side mirrors don't notice it these
everyday drivers in front of a fucking
tank blowing through military vehicles
on the highway are not in any way amazed
or concerned that's ludicrous defy the
laws of physics realize also that still
leaves all of you doing your own thing
and guessing why not at least talk
through the improvisational plant also
will improvise a whole thing special
place on the highway where we can
magically turn around and follow them
faster plucky that you missed or lucky
to the motherfucking tank that's been
absolutely destroying cars mainly bumps
into Romans car after you miss turn that
paycheck tire you will believe a man can
fly Letty go take care of the cable you
need to be outside when the tank gets
thrown so something really bull can
happen to save your life
why would a pink tank be impeded in any
way by the weight of a single Mustang
wouldn't the cable break before the
Mustang stops the tank this movie is
fast and spirits this movie took an
interesting twist because the remainder
of it will be about how DOM and Letty
help their friends in the afterlife
because though they appear to be living
right now I assure you they die Homs in
his helicopter arrived way too late to
matter but only because cell phones and
radios don't exist in this universe for
just this 10 minute stretch can't
believe they stole a 70-ton tank for a
three-ounce computed you okay so 70 tons
that tank 70 tons were in any way slowed
down or stopped by a fucking Mustang you
in the ear movie nobody makes me do
anything I don't want to except Sean the
entirety of this movie until this point
but yeah I hear you
so what's our next adventure after this
marriage how did you know that there
would be a car there break our fall
honey that is really the most minor of
the questions that you should be asking
as to why you survived all that bull we
just saw three minutes ago one quarter
mile at a time so he's got me a hostage
great doesn't the greater good still
demand they don't let him go right now I
mean I like Mia too but let's use our
heads here people but this changes
nothing
Hobbs character changes whenever the
script needs to be good bad or somewhere
in between words like Amnesty and pardon
walk out with them where's six movies in
I don't think it matters whether or not
these assholes are wanted by cops come
in bed
of course this so-called surprise only
serves to make me even angrier about
this movie also yeah like you didn't
have use for her anymore planted inside
Hobbes crew do you need the surprise
reveal now why she can join you at any
time it should be noted that during Hans
dumb surprise that Riley is not a good
person he's not holding a gun to the
NATO guy anymore these bad guys are
completely in the open and could be shot
but I guess they really care about me
and like the audience does actually I
think the past 40 minutes of this movie
probably needs an extra hundred sins for
no reason everyone cool with that no too
bad this movie is really really hard to
swallow on any basis even if it's just a
fun stupid movie it's kind of hilarious
the Gina Carano the worst actor in this
movie ends up playing the surprise mole
a character that would have to be the
best actor among them to actually pull
off the job I just jammed every signal
up and down the spec
let's move so your plan is to go after
an attack a guy that you just had right
in front of you with none of that he has
a hostage situation changed whatsoever
why couldn't you Jam the signal before
he left and just shoot his ass tyrese
enough this runway is long enough for a
plane to land board moving cargo and I
presume takeoff again since this movie
has no regard for common sense is as
good as dead if Shaw gets away on that
plane just in case you or anyone in the
audience needed reminding of that rider
die now that I've hit my already as far
as it goes gear shift I'm really gonna
start driving fast they brought me all
the way here
but why meanwhile these assholes don't
close the ramp or guard it allow me easy
access for Dom to speak to the rescue if
these vehicles are going 60 miles an
hour then this runway is already over
two miles long this is the chick who
just got crashed by a car by the way
this fight is interesting because you
already fought once but you were both on
the same side so all that was pretend or
did Letty not know that this trick was a
double agent
which means this fight is just a rehash
and I'm gonna call you lazy less weight
than you were expecting some of the bad
guys and their jeeps didn't make it into
the plane and only Dom's car drove in so
what a bunch of bullshit is what I'm
saying
you took that harpoon thing with you how
convenient if the plane in cars chasing
it are going at least 60 miles per hour
and they are then this runway is now
over four miles long Dom knew that a
precisely timed headbutt would knock
this guy so far back it knocked him out
and saved Brian at the same time two
heavy cars drive off the plane but the
pilot still can't get the plane in the
air they probably forgot about that wait
nonsense when they made this scene
everything about this mission is
rescuing Mia who is now rescued so
naturally Brian drives her right back
into the action
[Applause]
you're also Brian just knew this ramp
car hitting him would merely pop him up
in the air harmlessly because he's
Batman wherever this asshole came from
man I no longer have any clue what the
fuck is going on I'm still pretty mad
Letty live runway now it's six miles and
Counting if you're keeping track but of
course this movie is just for fun so
you're not supposed to give right you
mean just now the Rock fights discount
Brock lesner alley you punch something
random is within arm's length to get out
of choking cliche Palms has the luxury
of wasting time to throw this to let he
rather than just smoking Riley with it
himself meanwhile Riley just stands
there let's all this happen rather than
using her considerable reflexes to
tackle Letty or anything that might save
her this movie is the kind of thing
fourth grade me made up in the bathtub
with Star Wars action figures I'm pretty
sure this runway spans 150 miles I mean
this Chase has been going on without one
single turn in another direction for at
least eight minutes yeah also these
assholes should enter all the lotteries
impossible things excitement
don't worry Han he'll show up with
amnesia and working for the bad guys two
movies from now and you'll be able to
turn her back by giving the history of
all her scars also taking out your gun
and shooting people with amazing
precision is possible at these speeds
when you're falling from a Jeep that is
harpoon to a plane taking off more
thrilling punching movie rips off bad
guy death from Incredibles which ripped
it off from die hard to which ripped it
off from Raiders in the lost art jumping
from one speeding thing to another is
just like breathing in this movie
double goddamnit purple god damn it all
the good guys will survive this the
acceptance of like this is why we can't
have good movies Lettie it's just a
wreck that kills people Tom will be fine
not even at the end of the runway yet
and it's been 12 miles you can sit back
and drink your Red Bull and blam all you
want about how these movies are escapist
fun and you're not supposed to take them
seriously but I'm still gonna put your
sister later tonight the end of the
runway finally shows up when the action
is over as if they built the runway for
this movie or something Don is fine and
I'm okay with that
wait a minute I am NOT okay with that
dear romance Oh Mia that's greedy try to
keep him out of travel oh I guess this
trip needs to get on eHarmony now look
under all the available widowers you
know honestly I think Corona and this
franchise are a perfect match
seriously both are enormous ly popular
despite being complete with glossy
marketing you know your daughter girl
dumb
that's fuckin greedy recent love
interest is way more cool about
boyfriends other recent love interest
showing backup than any real person
would actually be I'm glad these
criminals finally did enough wrongs to
make a right movie thinks that in any
world there wouldn't be at least 10
deaths because of this stunt I'm gonna
go ahead and tell everyone whether you
believe me or not then I called this
before it even happened or looked at any
spoilers this franchise is not too far
away from becoming the Expendables and
this is proof
into Detroit
[Music]
they say most of your brain shuts down
in cryosleep all but the animal side
guess it's why I'm still awake maybe
it's because you don't realize how much
you appreciate something until somebody
takes it away
[Music]
cheese's
know what they say will work for you do
not really know someone I do you buy
them
[Music]
hey everybody if you have an interest in
a book about disabled superhero kids I
just happened to write something like
that and you can now pre-order the eBook
version the audiobook is coming soon as
well
[Music]